how important is confidence
you need to be the man that other men
want to be and other women want to bang
pretty much and pretty much exactly what
you just said here confidence is a as
you as victoria was saying confidence is
a security benefit so that's when when
somebody makes the reservations for you
and does all this stuff and it's like
we're going here tonight and we're going
to do this tonight it has a direction
and has a plan that guy yeah as you even
said he can protect me he can provide
for me that is exactly what i was
talking about ten minutes ago when we're
talking about maybe you worded it
different but yeah i love when you can
relax and trust the man the dude's in
control it's a it's a security but
benefit i'm not just gonna do that
around anyone can you fake confidence
like do you know the guys who are like
yeah i'm the man and then it turns out
it's like they're compensated i hate
that what is that like the false bravado
what are your thoughts on that i feel
like that is everywhere in miami and
it's the biggest turn off like give me
like what you thought they were and what
they turned out to be give me that story
um
you go first i don't know okay when i
look i can see the difference
immediately tell me that yeah exactly
you can kind of just tell like who's
flexing and
i don't know sometimes even when guys
spend money like too lavishly it's like
a turn off because
it's true there are subtleties to it
yeah it like has to be done in like a
classy way but
i agree with you where if you see
if you're brought into their life and
you see how they engage with other
people and they're confident in that way
like that's more attractive than them
showing you they're confident
you know something else with this the
men who i know like that
they are so
amazing their social skills are
impeccable and they're polite to
everybody they're appreciative of
everybody they're just really top-notch
individuals
you've you've said something one time
before like how how how can a man
improve their market value well uh okay
so as far as there's three well let's
yeah well let's uh well there's uh make
money make muscles learn game and then
have frame as a result of that that's
what we were talking about in patrick's
show
but what you both of you have just
described is what i've called the
hypergamous filter it's finding who's
the [ __ ] artist and who's not
women have classically called this
feminine intuition right that's oh i i
just figured him out because i i have a
good eye for these guys
i can i i can i can find out what this
guy's really about we also have training
and deception detection
okay so but let's just say for sake of
argument most women think that they have
an in uh what is it a feminine intuition
and really where that comes from is we
do look at the need it's the need to
find out whether that guy is for real or
he's not for real and i think that even
shows like the bachelor for example is
this
it's this testing it's this constant
qualification to see is he the real is
he the real deal or is he not the real
deal and that's why those shows and
anything that sort of uh triggers that
female indignation triggers into that
idea that um i got to figure out if this
guy is the real thing or he's not and
when women don't have that in their
lives they'll go and find it out
vicariously through like a tv show or
book romance novels whatever else to
find out is this guy real or is this a
guy not real because that in in our
evolutionary past that used to be a
matter of life or death she had to find
the right guy and if he wasn't the right
guy she could die it was
literally even if she found the right
guy and he turned out to be the wrong
guy it could be a matter of life or
death and so it's this sort of like
innate wiring in women to want to be
able to find out that's why women are
better at communication than men are
when i mean they understand subtleties
they understand like body language vocal
intonations uh you name it women can i
mean this is like proven studies show
that like women are better at
communication men are tend to be more
overt and our communication women tend
to be more covert as a result of trying
to figure out whether those guys are
honest or they're not i think that the
world is changing and
men
are being embraced for their
conversation skills and if you even
listen to what we were both attracted to
it is their conversation skills their
people skills so i think the men that
develop those
qualities that are at an advantage so do
you think that a man can develop his
communication skills so well that he can
trick you into bed
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes i think no
do you really think that the woman
doesn't know what's going on and this is
this is the part that is just painful
and this is why i stopped with men for
quite a long time i love the sex i
cannot stand the idea that you feel like
you tricked me into
something no it's not true okay oh no no
oh my god it was such a great game it's
because i have obviously no agency of my
own i had no idea what was going on the
entire time you were just so masculine
you were just so tricky
it's awful but that
you want to take this don't hate the
player hate the game we wouldn't be
talking about game in 2022 if it didn't
have some validity to it yes if there
wasn't some way you could call it swag
you can call it game you can call it
pickup challenge you can call it charm
a guy can turn up the charm and turn up
the confidence
if he's interested in you he can turn
like like it's not stagnant if a guy's
like yeah i don't really give a [ __ ]
like
like for instance my best friend who's
like don juan demarco over here is
always like dude i need you to like wing
it up wing it up like be my wingman
and if i'm into the girl i'm like hey
how you doing you know but if i'm not
into the girl i'm like dude if i can
waste my time on a sitter with this
[ __ ] girl but i think that's so weird
a guy can turn up the charm if they're
interested in you so you can might call
it game you might call it charm whatever
it is but social skills but it's just
business by the way
we're attracted to is the guy who's just
genuine and all around that person like
the guy who turns it on and off isn't
attractive because we can see through
that so i think like the guy who is
genuine
is
the one who can get it can a guy
simulate genuine no we could see through
it
that's just okay that's true that is
true that's the one thing i don't think
you can fake is genuine
okay so i mean you can simulate a bunch
of other stuff but actually
like listening and caring and hearing
what you're saying like
the the one cup the one class in college
that i actually remember taking that has
served me well was a class called
listening
and like the whole
point of it was like
you've got one mouth and two ears for a
reason and when someone else is talking
don't just wait to say your turn
actually listen because that's that's
how you'll have dialogue and that's how
conversations will progress you ever
been to a carnival and you walk by uh
the guy who will guess your weight or
guess your age or within a certain
tolerance right there that's called cold
reading okay so do you not think that so
people can i mean they make a good good
living off of it right i mean you okay
i'll bet you ten dollars that i can
figure out like what your weight is or
where you're from even like or what's
your sign right um that kind of stuff
there are guys who are very good at cold
reading and what it is is it's a it's a
skill that is developed over a course of
you know being out there and doing it
to the point where they and you know
psychics can do this as well it's like
they can see what you're about listen
like you're listening right trying to
figure you out knowing what the
commonalities are and then being within
that area of tolerance right there so as
a result of understanding and reading
you i know it's i know it's really
insulting because women don't want to
think that they're
something they're easier to figure out
but there's there are people who have
that skill to read you and know what
you're about a good salesman do it
do have all the
definitely have that skill i just um
i don't live my life that way so i
but i know people have that skill like a
lot of people from new york not saying
it's right or it's wrong i'm saying
there are people who can do that and
people who do it really well whatever
you wouldn't know the difference i think
that you should never project your
judgments onto a person just because
like i just have a different belief than
is it a judgment to say i can figure out
you're 29 years old just because you're
walking through the carnival
um
i don't want to go to the car
i don't know
what i mean is like somebody can read
you and understand stuff about you just
by looking at you you guys have just
said this a minute ago i can always
sniff out a faker right well how do you
do that you have to do a judgment call
to see that this guy is a faker
am i right
you